yuri besmanov did did you and yuri ever
meet did you ever meet yuri
no no you're the first one no you're not
the first one there is a uh
there's an aura around basmanov
that he he built up and uh gullible
conservatives in the united states
ate up
the man was a fraud
i'm sorry i'm sorry to disappoint you
tell me why he's a fraud and based on
which uh specimen of first of all
bezemanov was never kgb okay that's a
fact
bezmanov
had an association with the kgb
as a journalist
uh his his travel to the united states
is is
quite interesting at one point he he was
stationed in india and he decided to
defect in some way
and so he
he uh
disguised himself as a hippie and he
traveled around in india for a while and
eventually
he he must have connected with the cia
and wound up in the united states
and so your bresmanov wasn't much of
anything so he had to make a living
and smart enough he was he concocted
this whole idea how the how the soviet
union had this master plan
to you know in stages to undermine the
united states
yes they had a power how do you know
i'm curious
so
from your i was expecting you to say
something like the way you did i fully
expected you to undermine yuri a million
percent because i know your background
and i know which side you are
politically but i'm curious to know from
your end how do you know for a fact he
uh was a fraud how do you know he was
not the real deal okay all right um
he was not kgb how would he the if the
kgb was good at something very good at
something and anybody who has yeah uh
has had any contact with the kgb and was
keeping things secret
if they had had this master plan a
journalist who's not even in the kgb
wouldn't know anything about it
number one number two and this is this
is my own
observation
i was trained by some of the best
because i was one i was one of the few
elite agents that they sent in the
united states they had to give me the
best and some of those folks had uh
spent some time in the united states
as you know diplomats or maybe
journalists and they thought they knew
something about the united states
and they didn't because what they the
advice they gave me and the stuff they
taught me was was off the wall wrong not
correct and it is pretty much uh
uh
acknowledged
in an agreement that
neither the the the uh the united states
knew very much how the soviet uh
um
society operated and neither did the
soviet union but what i'm trying to ask
is how do you know he was a fraud though
how how do you for a fact know yuri was
a fraud i'm curious
no i'm just saying it out loud because i
don't know for a fact okay so you're
just speculating is what you're saying
that is but it's speculation that's
based on uh personal knowledge and it's
based on
um
if he had if the kgb had had such a plan
as i said they wouldn't have told him
secondly i know what they did and i know
you know if you're familiar with active
measures
very much so okay active measures
was a focus
particularly on dropoff was and this
this comes this this is factual this
comes out of the archives of the kgb uh
there's a guy who was archivist and he
smuggled out a bunch of material that
bites by the name of mitrokin
and
and active measures were somewhat
successful and that's how you try to
undermine the united states but if that
was the best they had
what was
where's the uh where does the other plan
come from they couldn't even come up
with one what do you mean it makes no
sense stalin came up with it in 1923
where you know
the disinformation program that was come
up with years ago subversion by sun tzu
which the ultimate way to beat your
opponent is to manipulate and think
you're not really fighting them by using
somebody else in a proxy war and they
were very effective
i mean if you if you're going to say
so so here's what i want to do here's
what i'd want to do i want to play the
clip of yuri and you know which clip i'm
going to play for you and i'm going to
go through the three steps and i want
you to
tell me which part of what he says is a
complete line doesn't make sense i'm
just
curious well you spoke several times
before about ideological subversion that
is a phrase that
i'm afraid some americans don't fully
understand
when
the soviets use the phrase ideological
subversion what do they mean by that
ideological subversion is is the slow
process
which we call either ideological
subversion or active measures
activeness in the language of the kgb or
psychological warfare what it basically
means is to change the perception of
reality of every american
to such an extent that despite of the
abundance of information
no one is able to come to sensible
conclusions
in the interests of defending themselves
their families their community and their
country
it's a great brainwashing
process which goes very slow and it's
divided into four basic stages
uh the first one being demoralization it
takes from 15 to 20 years to demoralize
the nation why that many years
because this is the minimum number of
years which requires to
educate one generation of students
in the country of
your enemy
exposed to the ideology of the enemy in
other words marxism leninism ideology is
being pumped into the soft heads of of
at least three generations of american
students without being challenged or
counterbalanced by the basic values of
americanism american patriotism
the demoralization process in the united
states is basically completed already
uh for the last 25 years
actually it's over fulfilled because
demoralization now reaches such areas
where previously not even commerce and
drop off and all his experts would would
even dream of such a tremendous success
most of it is done by americans to
americans thanks to lack of moral
standards as i mentioned before
uh exposure to true information does not
matter anymore
a person who was demoralized
is unable to assess true information the
facts
tell nothing to him
uh even if i shower him with information
with authentic true documents with
pictures
even if i take him by force to the
soviet union and show him concentration
camp he will refuse to believe it
until
he is going to receive a kick in the in
his fat bottom
when the military boot crashes his balls
then he will understand but not before
that that's the tragic of the situation
of demoralization so which part of what
yuri just said do you disagree with now
let me just start with what i agree with
he talks about active measures and that
is accurate that's correct
he also talks about uh
the uh
the demoralization of the nation of and
he actually makes a a good point
uh this is primarily happened that
happened internally
all right
and and a lot of this in my view started
with with the vietnam war and the the
anti-war protest movement
he does not make
the connection he doesn't connect the
dots between what the kgb did
and what happened in the united states
that is not there and he can't make it
because it can't prove it forget about
that i don't care about that what i care
about is how much of what he's saying
actually was done and has credibility
because it's tough to dispute
that russia didn't successfully inject
the spirit of communism and karl marx in
u.s universities and get younger kids to
believe that marxism is the way to go i
mean if you look at some of the surveys
that's coming up right now from harvard
university 64 of america students at
harvard support socialism and they don't
like capitalism so it so it was an
effective method wasn't it
yeah but the question is how did that do
it and who did it they didn't have a lot
of people in the united states that
could have done this this was this was
home
homegrown
communism and this whole idea of you
know everybody getting along together is
an extremely attractive ideology for
young people you don't need much now
there there there have been uh liberal
socialist streaks in in america in
america historically
uh
going all the way back
and they have grown and they have they
have uh
particularly taken hold in in
in universities and academia and and so
i agree that we now have already two
generations who have been taught
by people who beca who became
anti-american during the uh the vietnam
war now did these the soviet camp
contribute to all of this of course we
did but the kgb itself and this is where
where i i think i'm saying that uh
desmond officer fraud had nothing to do
with it because they weren't really
capable of doing what he said they were
doing
they weren't really capable of doing
what they said okay
let me let me let me uh
trying to
point out the facts of the matter
uh the active measures as as
as i said uh ander andropov who was in
charge in the in the 80s active he
actually issued a
command that everybody in the kgb would
should be involved in active measure
time it was really important to them
yeah but the department in which active
measures were were executed uh
was not very uh uh
desirable
so you know director first directorate
the one that did espionage that was the
number one the
did i forgot the directorate that did
active measures
uh
that was for losers this is a quote out
of midtroken that came out of the study
of the archives of the kgb
they had some successes and they failed
miserably in in many other respects
now
i'll give you a couple of successes
uh j edgar hoover being a cross-dresser
that was planted by the kgb
uh the cia inventing the aids virus that
was planted by the kgb
uh and there were a few other uh uh
cases where they were able to jay edgar
hoover
hoover was never a cross dresser
no he wasn't
you're saying j edgar hoover was never a
cross-dresser it was not
i mean
i can only tell you that
assuming that the uh the notes that
mchoken took in the archives are
absolutely 100 good and i tell you what
uh there there's a lot of um proof that
they are that we don't know about
because there's a lot of agents that
uh went belly up after the uh these
notes that came out so assuming assuming
that he's correct he says that was an
active uh he traces his back
uh how this story was planted so if you
like this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye